Adam laxalt is living through this right
now he's running for Senate from the
state of Nevada as we told you earlier
he joins us from there now and I'm like
so thank you so much for coming on what
is the state of your race tonight
well we feel really really strongly
about where this race is heading uh
we've been in late obviously since
election night that lead has shrunk over
the last few days but she does not have
the amount of votes left to be able to
catch us she'd have to win by over 63
percent and it's important to note since
most of the national media is not
covering this the Las Vegas mail ballots
that are being reported include election
day drop-off mail that mail is
absolutely not going to break like you
know traditional mail through the USPS
those are election day voters and just
to give you an example in Washoe County
we had more Republicans drop off
election day ballots than Democrats and
so again as we put out the math for the
world she has to win by over 63 percent
of all of this and we think that these
election day ballots you know could
break even we could stand to lose them
by 15 20 points and we would still hold
and so we feel like we're in a great
great position and uh just super proud
of my team and a lot of hard work
incredibly tough race but uh we're going
to win this thing hopefully and uh the
important race for the country and my
great state well we certainly agree with
all of that but we should know by now
it's been two days and Clark County
Nevada where most of our viewers have
been since it's one of the country's
biggest tourist destinations is one of
the most technologically advanced places
in the world you built a replica of the
Eiffel Tower in your county
everything is automated in Clark County
Nevada so I I'm honestly confused as why
they can't give us the results of an
election within a few hours
you know I absolutely believe we need to
get rid of ballot harvesting and drop
boxes and Universal mail out balloting
there's no reason first we don't even
have we don't even have voter ID we need
voter ID we need election day counting
as everyone keeps pointing out if
Florida can do a 21 million people with
3 million people in Nevada we should
know the results election and you know
here's what people's missing is the
human toll never mind like the Democracy
piece which is obviously the most
important you have campaigns and staffs
that are now just continuing for 20
hours when is the campaign over when do
you get to tell your supporters thank
you for everything you did we've won you
know when do you get your family to
actually breathe that it's over this
system is very very flawed and by the
way everyone knows it I think
Republicans and Democrats think this is
just an astonishing process and I don't
think in Clark County we did so much to
make sure this was a secure election we
have lawyers everywhere we had election
observers we feel confident that the
votes the the register announced today
they're just over 50 000 more mail votes
and you know total 70 000 tops so we
know the universe and we feel
comfortable with the universe but
nonetheless we need to change the system
yeah I mean it's like a Roman Siege
they're trying to wait you out uh but
we'll be following so I appreciate you
coming on tonight good luck
thanks so much
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight